well bread you touch upon the very heart
of the quantum theory in Newton's theory
the theory proposed 300 years ago a dot
represents matter and it's just a dot
that's all it is
these dots can reform collide with each
other orb a certain equations but they
don't vibrate then in 1925 Along Came
quantum mechanics which says that these
dots of matter the electron the proton
are not really dots at all in some sense
they're waves waves of vibration things
are waving and this means that our
bodies are actually waving as well this
is the basis of wave mechanics the fact
that particles have wave-like properties
then the embarrassing question is what
is waving what is it that is waving the
answer is that you're not going to like
this the answer is that what is waving
is the probability of finding that
particle at a given point
so let's now summarize it in one
sentence according to the quantum theory
matter is made out of dots but the
probability of finding the dot at any
given point in space and time is given
by a wave now then you raise a question
what happens if you change the
vibrations of these waves can you then
drift into other universes can you then
drift into other planes of existence and
at the atomic scale the answer is yes it
turns out the waves can split at certain
key junctures like an ocean wave can hit
a barrier and then we have two ocean
waves so it is possible that quantum
events can actually split universes
apart separated by probability a 50%
probability of this happening or that
happening so let's take for example
Hitler's mother let's say a cosmic ray
went through Hitler's mother a cosmic
ray is a quantum event there is let's
say a 50-50 chance that Hitler's mother
will then have an abortion I may have a
spontaneous abortion a miscarriage and a
50% probability that she won't have
a spontaneous abortion that you will
have a full-term child
Adolf Hitler so we now have the fact
that because everything vibrates two
universes have now separated and one
universe has no World War two
all of a sudden 60 million people didn't
have to die while the other universe is
our universe now this sounds like
science fiction right the only
difference between this and science
fiction is that the scenario I've given
you comes from modern physics this is
the basis of our industrial present-day
Industrial Revolution think of
transistors think of GPS the internet
television radio all the wonders of
modern technology they're all based on
the idea that electrons are waves and
these waves in turn are waves or
probability and the probability can
bifurcate confusion and universes can
then emerge from other universes so when
I look at myself in a mirror well most
people would say I see me in the mirror
well I don't look at it that way first
of all when I look at myself in a mirror
I say to myself I'm looking at myself as
I was a billionth of a second ago
because that's the time it takes for
light to go over my face of the mirror
in fact I'm not really looking at me at
all
I'm looking at me as I was a billionth
of a second ago in the past second of
all I'm not really well-defined I'm
really a mixture a mixture of different
kinds of waves now these waves really do
look like me if I were to get graph
paper and graph these way by god they
really do look like me except for one
crucial difference parts of the wave
lose off its a wave it was us off to
Mars to Jupiter to outer space parts of
me lose in all directions so there's a
finite probability that I will go to bed
tonight and wake up on Mars tomorrow now
of course it's a very small probability
I can calculate it I would have to wait
longer than the lifetime of the universe
for that to happen so chances are I'm
not going to wind up on Mars tomorrow
however
is possible and I can even calculate the
probability that I will wake up on Mars
tomorrow so anyway to answer your
question a everything is vibrating be
these vibrations are vibrations of
probability C universes do separate
universes do separate and do all sorts
of crazy things but in the main they
average out so when I look at myself in
the mirror on average that is me but
that's only an average part of me is on
Mars today and part of you is also on
Mars believe it or not